On a typical day at school, endless hours are spent learning the answers to questions.
But right now we'll do the opposite.
We're gonna focus on questions where you can't learn the answers because there are none.
I used to puzzle about a lot of things as a boy.
For example, what would it feel like to be a dog?
Do fish feel pain?
How about insects?
Was the big bang just an accident?
Is there a God?
And if so, how are we so sure that it's a him, not a she?
Why do so many innocent people and animals suffer terrible things?
Is there really a plan for my life?
Is the future yet to be written?
Or is it already written? We just can't see it.
But then, do I have free will?
Who am I anyway? Am I just a biological machine?
But then, why am I conscious?
What is consciousness?
Will robots become conscious one day?
Well, I kind of assume that someday, I would be told the answers to all these questions.
Someone must know, right?
Guess what? No one knows.
Most of those questions puzzle me more now than ever.
But, diving into them is exciting because it takes you to the edge of knowledge, and you never know what you'll find there.